we now know that if we have two
triangles and all of their corresponding
sides are the same so by side side side
so the corresponding sides all three of
the corresponding sides have the same
length we know that those triangles are
congruent what i want to do in this
video is explore if there are other
properties that we can find between the
triangles that can help us feel pretty
good that these those two triangles
would be congruent so side side side
works what about angle angle angle so
let me do that over here what about
angle angle angles what i'm saying is is
if let's say i have a triangle like this
like i have a triangle like that and i
have a triangle like this
and if we know
if we know that this angle is congruent
to that angle
if this angle
is congruent to that angle which means
that their measures are equal or and
i should say and and that angle is
congruent to that angle can we say that
this is that these are two congruent
triangles and in first case it looks
like maybe it is at least the way i drew
it here but when you think about it you
can have the exact same corresponding
angles being having the same measure or
being congruent but you can actually
scale one of these triangles up and down
and still have that property for example
if i had this triangle right over here
this triangle right over here it looks
similar
and i'm using that in just the everyday
language size it has the same shape as
these triangles right over here and it
has the same it has the same angles that
angle is congruent to that angle
this angle down here is congruent to
this angle over here and this angle over
here is congruent to this angle over
here so all of the angles and all three
of these triangles are the same the
corresponding angles have the same
measure but clearly clearly this
triangle right over here is not the same
it is not congruent to the other two the
sides are have a very different length
this side is much shorter than this side
right over here this side is much
shorter than that side over there and
this side is much shorter over here so
with just angle angle angle you cannot
say that the
a triangle has the same size and shape
it does have the same shape but not the
same size so this does not imply this
does not imply congruency so angle angle
angle does not imply congruency it what
it does imply and we haven't talked
about this yet is that these are similar
triangles so angle angle angle implies
similar let me write it over here it
implies similar triangles and similar
you probably are used to the word in
just everyday language but similar has a
very specific meaning in geometry and
similar things have the same shape but
not necessarily the same size so
anything that is congruent because it
has the same size and shape is also
similar but not everything that is
similar is also congruent for so for
example
this triangle is similar to all of all
of these triangles are similar to each
other but they aren't all congruent
these two are congruent if their sides
are the same i didn't make that
assumption but if we know that their
sides are the same then we can say that
they're congruent but neither of these
are congruent to this one right over
here because this is clearly much larger
has the same shape but a different size
so we don't we can't have an aaa
postulate or an aaa axiom to to get to
congruency what about side angle side so
let's try this out side
angle side so let's start off with one
triangle right over here
so let's start off with the triangle
that looks like this i have my blue side
i have my pink side and i have my
magenta side
and let's say that i have another
triangle that has this this blue side it
has the same side same length as that
blue side so let me draw it like that
it has the same
length as that blue side so that length
and that length are going to be the same
it has a congruent angle right after
that
so this angle
and the next angle for this triangle are
going to be going to have the same
measure they're going to be congruent
and then the next side the next side is
going to have the same length as this
one over here so that's going to be the
same length as this over here so it's
going to be the same length and we don't
know and because we only know that they
have that these that the court that two
of the corresponding sides have the same
length and the angle between them and
this is important the angle between the
two corresponding sides are also of the
same measure
we can do anything we want with this
last with this last side on this one we
can essentially it's going to have to
start right over here you could start
from this point and we can pivot it to
form any triangle we want but we can see
the only way we can form a triangle is
if we bring this side all the way over
here and close this right over there and
so we can see just logically that if we
have if
for two triangles they have one side
that has the length the same the next
side has a length the same and the angle
in between them so this angle
let me do that in the same color this
angle in between them this is the angle
this a is this angle and that angle it's
the angle in between them this first
side is in blue
and this second side right over here is
in pink
and well it's already written in pink so
we can see that if two sides are the
same have the same length two
corresponding sides of the same length
and the corresponding angle between them
they have to be congruent there's no
other place to put this third side so
sas and sometimes it's once again called
a postulate an axiom or if it's kind of
proven sometimes it's called a theorem
this does imply that the two triangles
are congruent
so we will give ourselves this tool in
our toolkit we had the sss postulate now
we have the sas postulate two sides are
equal and the angle in between them for
two triangles corresponding sides and
angles then we can say that it is
definitely a these are congruent
triangles now what about and i'm just
going to try to go through all of the
different combinations here what if i
have something what if i have angle side
angle
so let me try that
so what happens if i have angle
side angle so let's go back to this this
one right over here so actually let me
just draw redraw a new one for each of
these cases so angle side angle so i'll
draw a triangle here so i have this
triangle
that so this would be maybe the side
that would be the side let me draw the
whole triangle actually first so i have
this triangle let me draw one side over
here and then let me draw one side over
there and that
this angle right over here i'll call it
i'll do it in orange
and this angle over here i will do it in
yellow
so if i have another triangle that has
one side being having equal measure so
i'll use it as this blue side right over
here so it has one side that has equal
measure and the two angles on either
side of that side or either either end
of that side are the same
will this triangle necessarily be
congruent we're just going to try to
reason it out these aren't formal proofs
we're really just trying to set up what
are reasonable postulates or what are
reasonable assumptions we can have as we
kind of for in our toolkit as we try to
prove other things
so that angle let's call it that angle
right over there it's going to be
they're going to have the same measure
in this triangle and if and this angle
right over here in yellow is going to
have the same measure on this triangle
right over here
so regardless so i'm not in any way
constraining the sides over here so this
side this side right over here could
have any length it could have any length
but it has to form this angle with it so
it could have any length and it can just
go as far as it wants to go in no way
have we constrained what the length of
that is and actually let me mark this
off too so this is the same as this so
that side can be anything we haven't
constrained it at all and once again
this side could be anything we haven't
constrained it up at all but we know it
has to go at this angle so it has to go
at that angle well once again there's
only one triangle that can be formed
this way we can say all day that this
length could be as long as we want or as
short as we want and this one could be
as long as we want it as short as we
want but the only way that they can
actually touch each other and form a
triangle and have these two angles is if
is if they are the exact same length as
these as these two sides right over here
so
these two this side will actually have
to be the same as that side and this
would have to be the same as that side
once again this isn't a proof
i'd call it more of a reasoning through
it or an investigation really just to
establish what are reasonable baselines
or axioms or assumptions or postulates
that we can have so for my purposes i
think asa does show us that two
triangles are
two triangles are congruent now let's
try another one let's try angle angle
side
let's try angle angle side and you know
in some geometry classes and you know
maybe if you have to go through an exam
quickly you might memorize okay side
side size implies congruency and that's
kind of logical side angle side implies
congruency and so on and so forth
i'm not a fan of memorizing it it might
be good for time pressure it is good to
sometimes even just go through this
logic if you're like wait does angle
angle angle work well no i can find this
case that breaks down angle angle angle
if these work just try to verify for
yourself that they make logical sense
why they would imply congruency
now let's try angle angle side
let's try angle
angle angle side so once again
let's say let's have a triangle over
here it has some side
so this one's going to be a little bit
more interesting so it has some side
that's the side right over there and it
has two angles and let me draw the other
the other sides of this triangle
i'll draw one in magenta and then one in
green
and it has there's two angles and then
the side
so let's say you have this angle
you have that angle right over there
actually i didn't have to put a double
because that's the first angle that i'm
so i have that angle which we refer to
as that first a
then we have
this angle
which is that second a
so if i know if i know that there's
another that there's another triangle
that has one side having the same length
so let me draw it like that it has one
side having the same length it has one
angle on that side that has the same
measure
so it has a measure like that and so
this
this side right over here could be of
any length
this side of here could be any length we
aren't constraining what the length of
that side is but whatever the angle is
on the other side of that side is going
to be the same as this green angle right
over here so for example it could be
like that and then you could have a
green side go like that it could be like
that and have the green side go like
that
and if we have so the only thing we're
assuming or the only thing we're
assuming is that this is the same length
as this and that this angle is the same
measure as that angle and that this
measures the same measure as that angle
and this magenta line can be of any
length and this green line can be of any
length we in no way have constrained
that but how can can we form any
triangle that is not congruent to this
because the bottom line is this green
line is going to have to touch this one
right over there and the only way it's
going to touch that one right over there
is if it starts is if it starts right
over here it starts right over here
because we're constraining this angle
right over here we're constraining that
angle and so it looks like angle angle
side does indeed imply congruency
so that does imply congruency so let's
just do one more just to kind of try out
all of the different situations what if
we have and i'm running out of a little
bit of real estate right over here at
the bottom what if we tried out side
side
angle so once again draw triangle
so it has one side there
it has another side there
and then i don't have to do those hash
marks just yet so one side then another
side
and then another side
and what happens if we know that there's
another triangle that has two of the
sides the same and then the angle after
it
so for example it would have that side
just like that
and then it has another side but we're
not constraining the angle we aren't
constraining we aren't constraining this
angle right over here but we're
constraining the length of that side so
let me color code it so that blue side
is that first side then we have this
magenta side
right over there
so this is going to be the same length
as this right over here but let me make
it at a different angle to see if i can
disprove it
so let's say it looks like that or
actually let me make it even let me make
it even more interesting let me try to
make it let me try to make it like
let me try to make it like that let me
try to make it like that so it's a very
different angle but now it has to have
the same angle out here it has to have
that same angle out here so it has to be
roughly that angle so it actually looks
like we can draw a triangle that is not
congruent that has the same two sides
being the same length and then an angle
is different for example this is pretty
much that i made this angle smaller than
this angle these two sides are the same
this angle is the same now but what the
byproduct of that is that this green
side is going to be shorter on this
triangle right over here so these aren't
you don't necessarily have congruent
triangles with side side
angle
so this is this is not necessarily
congruent not necessarily
necessarily or similar it gives us
neither congruency nor similarity